hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to do a demo
to determine the percent water in a few
different kinds of fruit and vegetables
specifically lettuce and red grapes
these are the things that you need for a
demo like this you need an oven and a
cookie sheet you need some aluminum foil
you need a scale you need whatever fruit
or vegetable you're going to be using
you also need a notebook and a pencil to
write down the masses the e-way and
you'll also need a calculator here's how
it works first of all we're going to use
aluminum foil to hold the different
fruits and vegetables because when we
dry them in the oven they will stick to
whatever surface there on the aluminum
foil keeps things from being too messy
you'll see here that our aluminum foil
hands are not heavy enough for their
masses to register on our scale so for
this experiment we're actually going to
just disregard the masses of the
aluminum foil pans since they are so
miniscule compared to the actual
vegetable so we'll start like this by
measuring our what I have shredded
iceberg lettuce the balance is tear and
we see that the lettuce weighs 40 grams
now we're going to figure out the mass
of the great the Great I have cut into
halves this helps increase their surface
area to volume ratio so that they'll dry
a little faster so here I'm going to put
them in the aluminum foil pan with the
with the side with that with the
flushing side up which will also help
them dry faster to get the best weight
you need to we tear after I fill the
aluminum foil with all the greats
so now the balance is tendered you'll
get the mask of our great 45 grams
now it's time to take our lettuce and
our grapes we're going to dry them in
the oven this will cause the water
that's inside the cells to move a plate
and then once you have dried lettuce and
dry great you will get the masses again
we will then be able to determine the
mass of the water that was lost by
getting the difference of the mass we
just took and the maps of the dried
lettuce and great this will allow us to
calculate the percent water of lettuce
and percent water of grapes and we will
then be able to compare the values that
we determine from this experiment with
reference values and published sources
now it's time to put the food into the
oven you should use an oven that is not
already preheated this is because if you
put the food into an oven it's already
preheated there is more likely to be
splattering which can change your
results so to decrease splattering put
the food into an oven that is cool that
way the slow heating up will prevent
spiring from economy so now it's in the
oven I'm going to set it to about 170
degrees Fahrenheit 170 degrees
Fahrenheit is about 77 degrees Celsius
we will let it bake for about an hour
remember this is when the water will
evaporate and eventually we will have
just the dried food in those little
aluminum foil pan will weigh those
subtract that mask from the mask when
the food was still wet and the
difference there will be the maps of
water lost then we can determine the
mass of the food that was water to the
percent of the mass of the food that was
why remember that we cut the great in
two halves and let them face up with the
flushing side up by increasing the
surface area we can increase the drying
time if you are interested in learning
more about the surface area to volume
ratio see my video on that subject now
let's look at our results after leaving
the lettuce of the grape in the oven at
that lower temperature for about an hour
to allow a partial dehydration I then
raised the temperature of the oven to
about 300 Fahrenheit just to allow the
dehydration to happen more quickly now
let's look at the numbers for lettuce
before dehydration so when the lettuce
still had all of its water content we
measured it at 40 grams after is at two
grams this means that the water content
of the original lettuce was 38 grams we
can now figure out what percentage of
the original lettuce mass was due to
water that is 38 / 40 which is equal to
about ninety five percent for the grapes
he found different results they were
originally 45 grams after dehydration
they were nine grams this means that the
water content of the original great
sample was 36 grams that means that the
percent water of the original grapes was
36 / 45 which is about eighty percent
water so we see here
at the great work about eighty percent
water the lettuce about ninety-five
percent water so with this experiment we
can see the water content of the various
foods that we eat it's easy enough to do
at home so I encourage you to try it you
can always google the percent water
value for whatever food you are working
with and see how close you got for
example I found reference values online
for grapes that agree with eighty
percent and reference values online for
lettuce that said about 95 or 96 percent
showing that we got pretty close so
that's it for today I hope you enjoyed
watching and we'll see you next time on
biology professor